one follow-up on his greatest
achievements because I know Trump
constantly touts operation warp speed
and he held the covid-19 vaccine as one
of the greatest achievements of mankind
do you agree with him on that
yeah I I don't you know because of what
we know now I think at the time cutting
through that again you can't fathom that
a guy like a fauci and the people
developing this would do so in the
Affairs like being like if I get listen
I get it I'm a capitalist I understand
profit motive I understand this that the
other yada yada but like there's
people's lives
um you know I think it took all all of
that time and all of those years to
fully just understand how bad it
actually is
um you know again it's easy to be a
Monday Morning Quarterback and say I
would have done it differently but
but true and all the people that are
saying that now you see you look at
their social views I'm like oh really it
sounds like you were playing the exact
same game it's easy to say you would
have done it differently because there's
no way to prove and otherwise